I mouthed off to a kid that I knew he
but he was he was like your height he
was like six foot six right and I might
have been five three at the time and I
said something I I I scored on him or
something and I don't know I said
something but I but he he came for me so
before I knew it it was like I was on
the ground he was he was above me and it
was right then that little five foot two
Ben Affleck tackled this dude off of me
thank you
literally at the risk of his own life
like out of nowhere I was like a junior
and he was like a freshman
completely then everyone had broke it up
because they wanted to get back to like
the football game because that was fun
and this was ridiculous so that was the
end of it and the kid was reasonable and
he was like all right I'm not fighting
these all right let's let's play but I
remember that was like a big moment
going like this guy is like he will he
will put himself in a really bad spot
for me like this is a good friend and he
will be Batman
[Laughter]